did you and 21 savage ever have any
dialogue after the uh
very very
very loud back and forth where you
pretty much are like look at this it's
on site
i'm glad you brought that up because i
wasn't thinking about it like birdman
been on my ass about 21 savage almost to
a point i'm damn near jealous man
he ain't whack that's family man
savage family man
you a g
so what if he stepped out of line a
little bit you know he family you didn't
told me you [ __ ] with him i told you i
love the little [ __ ] to death you
supposed to swallow that and dealt with
that different like he he he another one
bird man he been on my ass about but me
and savage spoke the same day
um after the fact i think what it was
was somebody
somebody already told me savage
had a distaste for something i did and i
wasn't tripping so when they pinged him
to the room they told me he was down
there i'm like yo bring him up so i'm on
the impression i'm just going to ask him
yo savage what's the issue he's going to
tell me and we're going to have a
conversation because we both have mutual
respect for one another right but you
know he kind of told me somebody fed him
some other [ __ ]
you know what i mean to where when he
came into the room he was already
on charge because he was thinking
something totally different so you know
yeah so which triggered him up a little
[ __ ] look gangster you know a little
punk so you know he figures somebody's
saying this is saying these things about
him he coming in the room he's dealing
with the [ __ ] head on right i get it
understand it now so we had a
conversation in uh one of his rooms i
mean where we chopped it up people was
in a room this was after the uh
the very loud the one that went viral a
lot of men a couple hours later because
listen for people who don't know you you
have when you are
activated no listen i am like like you
know i i
this
businessman
father
uh but when you're but when your fuse is
gone i mean i know how to do that right
doing that is more
common for me and more natural to me
yeah than being this other dude you know
what i'm saying no matter you know with
age it don't do nothing but make you a
more grouchy a dog right right you know
what i'm saying that's all it does so
you know when it happened
because of who it was i think i did
great and that was probably due to my my
my my my wife i just telling me that i
need to learn how to you know deal with
my anger and not snap and have a short
fuse that's why i kind of like was
trying to deal with it but he just kept
coming and then you know it's always
this little man on my shoulder i can't
get rid of this [ __ ] man he
always
trying to tell me and remind me of some
[ __ ] i should be mad at and how i should
be reacting you know when i'm trying to
keep a focus my like this dude don't go
don't win i i don't i want to get rid of
him but then again i don't because he's
kept me alive
back gonna go down that block you know
what you got to do get off handle your
business get up out of there right this
he's part of my instincts you know i
mean so that's why when i when i when i
did talk to savage a couple hours later
he came out and said listen man you know
i thought this and thought that so the
way i came i might have came wrong and i
knew for him to say that after i had
approached him the way i did and we
approached each other i knew it was
genuine and it was some grown man [ __ ]
and he really was outclassing me at that
point in time for me to keep tripping so
i had to hear him out so we you know we
verbally talked and verbally was cordial
for like another 20 30 minutes toward
each other